there's a um
another very dangerous attempt at gun
control you see here's what's happening
if you go over to
gasprices.aaa.com the national average
gas price is four dollars and
86.5 percent you see gas is going to be
so expensive you'll be able to buy it
you can't afford the guns so there you
go uh no in all actuality yo gas prices
are nearing five bucks this is this is
apocalyptic but wait it's okay
joe biden is allowing solar panel
imports and he has said that this is a
robust recovery where are those solar
panels coming from oh sorry are they
coming from china china and where's
china
oh yeah
yeah and where's china getting the
minerals this is the big caveat where's
china getting the minerals to produce uh
those solar panels who is it do you know
anyone here
no no no no it's another place that uh
we left a lot of weaponry in afghanistan
afghanistan yes there you go it comes
all full circles
but again when we look at what the
government has been doing here these
prices
we're just going into peak driving
season these prices are going to go up
the demand is going to go up it's
somewhere dude yeah with these prices
everything else is going to go up it's
not just paying at the pump it's not
just paying for gas your groceries every
other item is going to rise in price
because of this domestic energy policy
that is shooting itself in the foot and
is literally creating this financial
havoc that we are dealing with some
people call this the great reset some
people are saying that we need to
destroy the old in order to build back
better those are the talking terms of
the biden administration
not mine and a lot of other globalist
and world economic forum types they're
the ones talking about this obviously
what's happening here to me is is
absolutely deliberate we are seeing the
financial destruction of the united
states from within the inside and we
still don't even know the actual numbers
of the secret federal reserve bailouts
that are bailing out all the big
corporations that have friends within
their government so things are scary
things are absolutely terrifying
especially when you look at the
financial situation i just want to say
um
gas prices are high in part due to joe
biden
intentional climate change actions
that's just not even up for dispute yeah
because you know it's more
environmentally friendly to import
energy from saudi arabia than it is to
produce it domestically here in the
united states and we get to prop up a
murderous dictatorship that keeps
assassinating children in yemen whatever
whatever is happening after the fact it
is a fact that joe biden said he was
going he was he was campaigning on
climate change he was going to reduce
carbon emissions all of that good
climate change stuff he shut down
keystone he banned uh uh
uh permits on certain federal land
recently banning in the gulf and a bunch
of other areas stopping exploration
stopping discovery this is deliberate
and this is
stated intentionally because of climate
issues and environmental issues and now
gas prices are going up partly due to
that there is a spike coming because of
ukraine that's effect especially with
europe and especially with us having to
help protect you know europe and and do
we can in terms of their energy we are
being hit by that as well but if you're
wondering why it's getting so crazy joe
biden's going to try and blame vladimir
putin but gas prices were going up well
before putin but the problem is the
mainstream media believes what joe biden
says on it if you if you watch the
mainstream media you think what's
happening right now what's been
happening for the last three months is
because of ukraine right that's what
they're doing it's terrifying well
i mean the problem is people believe in
the mainstream media about anything yeah
but there's a lot of americans who
believe the mainstream the journalists i
don't think believe joe biden well then
why are they putting it out there
because you're boys oh god because
they're tired
yeah they they lie that's why they're
like oh joe biden light again run it
that's it
well have you seen his twitter account
lately
it is like every day he's blaming
someone else for inflation and gas
prices it was meat producers oil
producers republicans trump
uh ukraine putin it's a different thing
every day and i was saying this that joe
biden is a sacrificial lamb they knew
that it was going to be really really
bad so they needed someone to run who
who's not going to win again they needed
a buchanan or somebody and they could
blame it on on him being old and having
cognitive decline but they won't even
admit that
not yet well this is a part of the game
we're arguing about that not the larger
destruction that's happening within the
united states two weeks ago the new york
post had a very eye-opening uh article
that was titled biden praises high gas
prices as part of an incredible
transition
so this is this is his own words and
this is the transition that we're going
through right now because this is
deliberate this is what they've been
talking about planning instituting and
doing for a very long time they don't
want you having freedom of mobility they
don't want you driving cars they don't
want you having freedom in your own
personal individual life and what better
way to do that than to take it away from
individuals by making it too expensive
and only allowing the super rich
individuals like john kerry to fly
around in their private jets and to
lecture everyone about how we need to
stop over consuming and have bill gates
buy out the media to promote his fake
meat because red meat is somehow bad for
you when the scientific data
specifically especially when it comes to
beef liver highlights the exact opposite
of that i keep going i'm about to
explode because this is a part again i
think this is all deliberate i i saw a
meme and people are like
when
you know after 9 11
we said oh well no we didn't we changed
the entire way that we board planes and
our responders like no only for poor
people like if you're rich you get
expedited or you get tsa pre if you fly
on a private plane there's no security
yeah i recently flew in a private plane
it was fantastic it was the first time
i've ever flown and it was a gift uh i
got i got lucky because someone happened
to go in the same way as me and they're
like come on you know take a ride and i
was like okay and we walk into the
airport and they're like hey i'm your
captain right this way and we just walk
straight through it's like 10 feet from
the door to the to the door to the
tarmac you walk on the plane not a big
plane it's very cramped but uh
you know the rich people they don't know
they don't got to wear masks they don't
have to deal with the blue glove tsa
agents patting down put in their hands
where they have no business placing
those hands in there yeah you know was
it elon's playing did you get a massage
was there a massage table in there it
was it's way too small for that okay so
you know look i'm looking not if you're
uh you know mr epstein let me let me
tell you guys something you know how
much it costs
from so so we we looked into this
from uh dc to austin
round trip private jet
just the base base low lowest rate how
much you think it cost 10 grand how much
do you think it costs a loop
private jet from
austin round trip
15 20
20. 55 000. oh my gosh it used to be way
cheaper a year ago two years ago but the
price of fuel has skyrocketed and
there's a shortage of pilots it's 55 000
and people do it all the time they do
have these things where they do these
pools where you buy like a percentage of
a fleet and then you can use it and then
you got to spend a couple grand per
flight or whatever but that's how much
it costs and guess what part of the
reason it's so high is because the
demand from the wealthy
they are willing to spend that to to
avoid the blue gloves going up and then
them you know up in your buttocks and
these are the uh often the elites who
are telling us how important these
security measures are i'm glad you
brought this up luke biden talking about
an incredible transition because it's
interesting i thought we were going to
see a return to normal because that's
what he promised but one of my favorite
things about this is here we see that as
is the case with transgenderism
transition is just a euphemism for
mutilation
fair point um another aspect of this
that i think is worth entertaining and
talking about is that the same time that
he he announced and made this very
important incredible transition
statement he also announced the plan to
set up more bike lanes uh especially in
city areas and set up more speed cameras
what is that going to do this is going
along with the the un 2030 vision the
world economic forum great great great
you know build back better this is
everything that they've always been
talking about dreaming about and one of
their key plans is to eliminate people's
ability to travel people's ability to
have a car and i i think this is the
larger plan because this is all for
allegedly global warming no it's really
about subjecting human beings to slavery
and controlling every aspect of their
existence what better way to do that
than even controlling their their
ability to move around they want you
living in those cities this is a part of
a larger agenda that has been building
up for a very long time and there has
been a huge attack on people's ability
to be able to drive you have to deal
with with inspections you have to deal
with regulations you have to deal with
with uh you know
so many regulations against diesel so
many environmental regulations but but
when we look at the people hurting the
environment they're the ones getting you
know a lot of the support a lot of the
tax money a lot of the government
socialism that goes directly to them
everyone else gets screwed it's paying
the ultimate price and i think this is
only going to get worse and i think this
is
not an accident that this is happening i
think this is deliberate lock step and
barrel every step of the way they are
pushing for humanity's total enslavement
and taking away people's ability to
drive is going to be one of those key
elements that they need to get rid of
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you